[Music]
there is an elevator in the elevator you
press the button to the floor with no
name behind those doors is life you
always tremble
[Music]
here this weekend you will be our galaxy
here anything and everything is possible
no service it's not everything is
possible
good evening I'm mr. Verret let me
officially welcome you to Fantasy Island
[Applause]
curious how this all works what if your
fantasy involves a person from your life
Holograms like Dubuc what if it's
somebody who died to possum so it's your
fantasy revenge on a childhood bully at
the your life is about to change
[Music]
I hope you're ready
that is really good holiday there is
only one fantasy per guess and you must
see your fantasy through it no matter
what
oh my god that's really her porch this
is not what I meant
what the hell is this place
people died here the islands twisting
what we asked
weren't brought here to have our own
fantasies we were brought here to be a
part of something else
I'm your friend
[Music]
[Music]